Let me pick up on our caller from the 3 1
5 area code who's been holding for a while.
Caller from 3 1 5. What's your name? Where
you calling from?
Yes. Hi, David. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Yeah, hi. I love that bit. I was trying to
think of doing a Scottish accent to try to
fool you, but I don't have good acting skills.
Fair. Hi, my name's Trist, and I'm calling
you from New York, no, but I'm currently in
Oregon right now. Got it. And I have a question.
I have a question about disabled people because
I feel like this kind of leads into a broader
issue about disabled people being left out
of the conversation within mainstream and,
quite honestly, independent media as well.
OK. Because, you know, right now during this
virus, disabled people are really suffering
significantly. I was just on an organizing
call this Monday. People were talking about,
you know, how difficult it was to. You know,
get essential services that they need. For
example, I'm blind, I can't see. So, you know,
when I'm you know, when I need to get groceries,
sometimes I have them delivered. But, you
know, I'm looking at delivery times and they're
just like way backed up extremely really high
demand. Right. So I think it's really important,
you know, to to consider disabled people in
this conversation that we're having about
essential services.
I completely agree with you. Now, how do you
what what grocery delivery service do you
typically use?
Typically use Instacart. Sometimes I use Walmart.
And what kind of an interface do you use to
navigate the Web site?
So I have an iPhone and as of like 2009, iPhones
have built in a technology called screen readers.
Right. And what that does, that takes the
text and that turns it into speech so that
I can understand it.
So let me ask you a question about that, because
I've seen that technology if you're on a Web
site. Yeah, if I go to the amazonfresh Web
site and I'm trying to do a grocery delivery
order, the screen is covered with stuff like
will the screen reader actually read to you?
The fact that there's before I even get to
the delivery time on the page, it says, like,
you know, books, customer service, contact
us, you like. There's all this extraneous
stuff that has nothing to do with me trying
to order groceries. Does the screen reader
read every single one of those words before
it gets to the relevant stuff?
Not always. So, like you can. There are shortcuts.
There are technical shortcuts. Like you can
go by heading you go by linking people by
landmark. You know, all different web elements
are organized in a way. Sometimes people have
a harder time utilizing it just because it's
it can be kind of complex, especially for
like older blind individuals who don't necessarily
have the technological skills that get a 25
year old guy like me has.
And let me just one other question about and
I hope I hope this is OK you ask. So when
the delivery shows up, what is the process
like? How do how do you know that it's your
Instacart delivery?
So, like, you know, I will usually get a call
or text message and then read it to me as
well, so like, you know, it'll say messages,
notification, so and so is trying to get a
hold of you, your Instacart deliveries here.
Got it. Got it.
Yeah. So how much we take for granted, right?
How much we take for granted when we when
we don't have something like that going on
in our lives.
Well, yeah, indeed, I think it's really, really,
really important that we talk about this.
There's a Twitter hashtag. We are essential
that where people can kind of submit their
stories and tell people what what things are
going on. I mean, this is a really serious,
serious matter and this is the first time
I've ever called into a show like yours.
Well, I'm glad. And I really appreciate the
work that you do. You know, I really think
Shater worthy. Do I know you?
It's them. What would you say is the most
difficult thing for you as a blind person
day to day that might not be on the radar
of people with with.
Honestly, people's ignorance is really difficult
to deal with. You know, when you're you know,
when you're in a big city trying to like navigate
the world that I'm a college graduate. And
so, you know, when you're in a big city trying
to navigate the world and people just have
all these different opinions of where you
should be and how you should be acting and
don't really understand really the things
that, you know, the technological advances
that we have and that really helped me a lot
and can, you know, a a bunch of opportunities
for blind individuals to navigate the world.
So I think that's the biggest thing to overcome.
Understood. Tristan Risk. Listen, I really
appreciate your call.
Yeah. Thank you for taking it.
All right. Kristin from Oregon, very good
to hear from him. Okay. Let's check in with
our caller from the 5 1 2 area code.
Who's calling 2 5 1 1? Boy.
Hi, David, this is Annie. Hey, Annie, what's
going on?
Thank you for being such a steadfast beacon
of hope for all of us. And Hasnat. As for
us all. And I. I feel any sense slighted and
undermined and so many levels. And I feel
that how the election was wrong in Wisconsin
is, in my mind, criminal. What do you thought?
Well, so I have two thoughts about that. I
mean, listen, Bernie lost by a lot. Bernie
lost by more than 2 million votes, maybe 2.5
million votes to Joe Biden. It wasn't close.
And I think it's important to understand that
in any analysis that we make. Now, as far
as the Wisconsin stuff, there have been people
saying, you know, in its present particularly
move now that Bernie has dropped out. But
a lot of people have said it was Bernie's
responsibility to drop out so that Wisconsin
wouldn't vote on Tuesday. That's not true
at all. There were local elections. There
was a judgeship on the ballot. It's not just
Bernie who needed to drop out in order to
stop the Wisconsin election. There was other
stuff on the ballot. So I think that criticism
of Bernie is completely unfair.
Rite Aid aguy.
Anything else on that, any? Now, I just wanted
to get that question in.
All right. Thanks, Andy. Great to hear from
you. Andy from I believe from Wisconsin, based
on based on the area code